esta mañana Rusia volvió a lanzar una
nueva serie de ataques especialmente
contra la capital kiev donde según se
dice se habrían atacado infraestructura
estratégica en la ciudad y también
algunas otras sectores A los alrededores
de kief este no solamente fue el único
ataque también en hard hubo ataques y
también en la provincia de Nicolás pero
lo que se conoce es que hay una nueva
serie de ataques que se están esperando
en este momento en el país aquí donde
nos encontramos en el donbas en la
ciudad de slobiank suenan las alarmas
hasta hace poco y están en alerta como
en la mitad del este de Ucrania así que
están esperando una nueva serie de
ataques esto En un momento en el que
sigue sin confirmarse si las tropas
rusas tienen el control total de esa
población de Soledad donde el Ministerio
de defensa ucraniano aseguraba que se
continuaban los combates hemos estado
transitando los alrededores de Soledad
hemos estado en Back mood y en esta
carretera esta mañana y nos cuentan que
si bien hay presencia ucraniana en las
afueras de Soledad que siguen algunos
combates allí nadie está entrando al
centro de la ciudad incluso uno de los
integrantes de las fuerzas especiales de
Ucrania nos decía que entrar allí era no
volver a salir